in the first case of its kind in Texas
five women are suing the state claiming
its abortion ban puts them in danger
Texas is one of 12 U.S states with the
most restrictive new laws since the
Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade
Janet shamlian spoke to one of the
plaintiffs who says she was not allowed
to claim a medical emergency
my heart broke into a
room gyrian was only 19 weeks pregnant
when her water broke her doctor told her
she had almost no chance of carrying her
baby to term and her own life was
threatened my doctor put it was like
it's a 50 50 shot that you'll get an
infection but a less than one percent
shot that you're going to leave this
hospital with the baby Texas doctors
told her they couldn't perform an
abortion so she traveled to Colorado
your home to have this done
it's terrifying I felt like a shell of a
human but I was just like
you know wrapped up in grief zargaryen
is now one of five women suing the state
of Texas over its abortion law it is now
dangerous
to be pregnant in Texas after the
Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade last
summer a state trigger law banned
abortion unless a woman's life is at
risk or the fetus has a fatal diagnosis
and doctors who provide the procedure
outside those limited circumstances face
the possibility of life in prison we
were honored to work on the Texas
heartbeat act John Siegel helped that
trigger law get passed he says doctors
need more education on what qualifies as
life-saving Texas law does not require
for a woman to be at death's door to
enact and to involve get involved and
actually save that woman the lawsuit
asked the court to clarify medical
exceptions zargaryen says she wants that
for other women and eventually
a healthy baby for her family
do you have hope
um you know I do uh
but at this point in my life it's just
really terrifying to think about getting
pregnant in Texas again
this suit comes as a federal judge in
Texas is expected to rule soon on a Case
challenging the fda's approval of the
common abortion drug muffa pristine that
ruling could impact access even in
states where abortion is protected Gail
all right got it Janet thank you